some of the most difficult to repair
damages of the Donald Trump era are
going to be the alliances that have been
ruined by Donald Trump's presence in the
Oval Office and indeed the United
Kingdom is now abandoning its alliance
with Donald Trump over the Iran crisis
and we've talked before about how the
United States is increasingly out of
important climate change discussions
worldwide why would you invite the
country that backed out of the Paris
climate Accords and whose President
believes climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese you wouldn't the
United staes is increasingly out of
those discussions the u.s. is
increasingly acting alone and
belligerently in international
agreements like the Iran nuclear deal
where Donald Trump decided we're just
simply going to bail we're gonna leave
everybody else in the deal out to dry
despite the reality that Iran did not
violate any element of that deal the
United States is increasingly running
afoul of our allies with actions like
Donald Trump's on Iran in the
unauthorized assassination of Kasim
soleimani which we've been covering and
now we've heard from the UK defence
secretary ben wallace who says that
donald trump's isolationist and
unilateral behavior is making the UK
look for alternative allies this is one
of our most important alliances and
they're saying we're looking elsewhere
here's Ben Wallace speaking to The
Sunday Times two days ago I wonder if
the United States withdraws from its
leadership around the world over the
last year we've had the u.s. pull out
from Syria the statement by Donald Trump
on Iraq where he said NATO should take
cover and do more in the Middle East the
assumptions of 2010 that we were always
going to be part of a u.s. coalition is
really just not where we are going to be
regardless of what the US does we are
going to have to make decisions that
allow us to stand with a range of allies
the five eyes that's the intelligence
partnership with the US Canada Australia
and New Zealand and our European allies
where our interests converge the United
Kingdom is publicly saying this isn't
just happening behind closed doors they
are publicly saying we're not sure
but our alliance with the United States
we are looking elsewhere they're also
looking at reducing their dependence on
US military assets Wallis saying we're
very dependent on American air cover and
American intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance assets we need to
diversify our assets which we could see
is good it's good that they be
independently sort of sustainable when
it comes to defense but it is also a big
red flag when it comes to foreign policy
and what we've seen as alliances over
the last many decades and meanwhile
Donald Trump is also threatening to
reduce intelligence sharing with the UK
so if you are a total like isolationist
nationalist type you want to build walls
instead of bridges and do everything
ourselves with nobody else you may
actually like this the problem is that
it's absolutely terrible for the United
States economically as well even if you
like isolationism politically and
theoretically in practice in 2020 when
our economy is so interlinked with those
of our allies in so many ways this is
very bad and the scariest thing about it
is that many trumpets aren't worried
they're not scared they're not concerned
about this because Donald Trump has
successfully primed them to see
everything he does as alpha behavior if
allies are abandoning us it's because
Trump has shown them I don't know that
he's doing what's best for the u.s. not
for them and they're realizing now that
Trump exists to make America great again
not to make the UK great so good for
Trump allies abandoning us as a sign
that Donald Trump is doing really well
and this is the type of post facto
reasoning that if Trump did it it must
have been good for the United States and
that makes the echo chamber very
difficult to pierce so this story is
about the alliances that will take a
long time to repair once Donald Trump is
gone but it's also a story about the way
in which a trumpet is able to justify
any action that Donald Trump takes if
it's a or if it's the opposite of a
either way it's Trump doing the right
thing if Trump did something that
impressed the UK and made them say wow
Trump did something good
you have Trump is saying look at what a
great job Donald Trump is doing or just
like he said he's making the u.s.
respected or whatever which Donald Trump
said we weren't under Barack Obama but
we would be again under Donald Trump if
our allies abandon us the same trumpet
will insist
Trump's doing what he promised it's
America first here it's make America
great again screw our allies Donald
Trump is here to do what's best for the
United States and then on the tail end
of this you have the geopolitical
considerations who will come in who will
take leadership responsibilities we've
seen it sort of to a degree be German
Chancellor Angela Merkel but this is a
perfect example of why Vladimir Putin
loves the instability caused by Donald
Trump a West that is increasingly
leaderless looking for a leader
realigning those alliances that's an
opportunity for Russia period and this
is you don't even have to get into Putin
help Trump beat Hillary it's not an
analysis of interference or any of that
it's simply an analysis of the real
world
Vladimir Putin benefits and sees
opportunity as a result of weakened
leadership in North America and Western
Europe and Donald Trump is perpetuating
that in this vicious cycle that is
endlessly defended by his followers in a
style reminiscent of a combination of
George Orwell's 1984 but of course also
brave new world by Aldous Huxley do you
feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen
to an entire non-fiction book in the
amount of time it takes you to drive or
walk home from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations
blinkie's has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for blinka
stay they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you